that's a first
there we go man where's the chest 960
when you need it played all these
different openings that's the first time
you're seeing this what do you call it
it's saying it on chess cube what do you
call that here's one pun you don't want
to touch now that you've moved here this
right here is probably one of the most
committal starts to a chess game g4 BAM
the grabs attack the grabs attack they
call that Bishop here
I feel like doing b4 as well this is
ridiculous and this right here is the
extent of my knowledge on the grabbes
attack b g4 g4 and that is about it
that's as exciting as it gets all right
I guess I'll let me just swing the bat
completely around here you do this for
two reasons
Bishop here bishop diagonal and also to
be a bug to this night just h3 h3 and
then we'll just kind of wait and see
here I don't want to do this right now
because I think age six becomes
problematic I don't want to have this
rook come off the board so I'm gonna I'm
gonna baby step it if something like h5
I'll do g5 and then maybe back a fought
with h4 so it makes things a bit
inconvenient for this night he can't
really rely upon f6 as easily I was just
a watch out for this advance okay here
we go
so now these guys are taken away so
where's this night going to develop all
right in the meantime I think I should
either do this no I'm going to do this
let my bishops see him watch over this
pond I didn't want to do h4 because it
allows the bishop to come here now
we do here I'll pawn push in the center
about night here and then I really feel
like playing a 3 B 4 which looks
absolutely ridiculous but maybe there's
something to it I'm gonna try it my
opponent has a good center I am looking
to maybe strike at it at some point
and let's do this cuz now maybe now
maybe what actually this is kind of
close to I better do that before the
knight comes here that'd kill me it's
kind of like that thunderhorse setup
that I'll do alright so clearly I'm
playing on the flanks my opponent has a
nice Center and to do that as pawns
getting hit a little scary here making a
lot of actually I've yeah pretty much on
the mini pawn rows except for this guy
so I want to get rid of this Knight oh
man I'm in trouble why did I see that ah
actually I'm still in trouble still in
trouble I'm still in trouble oh this is
gonna be a disaster this is gonna be a
big disaster right here let me tell you
I gotta come up with something let's
make sure the Queen's are off the board
I need to get this pawn this is this is
a problem so I need to do something like
that
fast because oh man that's a killer move
that's a killer move right there can I
somehow save this cuz it does not feel
right at all does not feel right at all
not at all here alright let's try this
my bishop is gonna have to play to e4 oh
this is ugly
that's last time my first and last time
I'm playing the grabs
I thought I'm supposed to be attacking
isn't this the grabbes attack why is it
white attacking ah what a disaster what
a disaster right here I can't deal with
this pin I think I need to get out of it
here
all right go I just kicked that guy away
a little bit get him out of there so
this is not fun at all
not at all maybe I should go here now
let me go here first I want to be able
to play here I it's so tough to even
find a good home for my king you know
what I'm talking about do you know what
I'm talking about I don't have a good
home for my king
it's a trade a little bit can we get
some trades here trades I'm at least
defending this with another piece now I
want another piece to be off the board
here can I make that happen now let's
try that
I need a trade I need a trade to happen
very soon I'm down on time as well trade
or not to trade let's go here I can't
let these rooks do stuff my King needs
to come over here something uh what a
bug
I can't even defend that this is bad
this is bad news I don't have anything
do I have to do this
I'll just rook takes pawn on it defends
the knight or takes pawn and I am dead
I'm a dead man I was thinking about b6
just to get to b5 I don't know what I do
I take C and I am in trouble trouble
City I have to do something about this
pawn and I'm not seeing anything good
happen except for this was my opponent
listening to the stream uh-oh uh-oh a
sneak attack I said my opponent up
that's the only resource I had that was
the only resource I had right there was
to just try and be sneaky with stream
tactics stuff that you do not see every
day stream tactics I needed right there
stream tactics they are tough not easy
to implement at all
maybe I'm completely wrong though maybe
my opponent wasn't I just try my best I
was trying my best right there um I
could still lose this very easily by the
way this Knight does not like to fend
off all these past pawns you have to
believe me when I say that come on come
on no you have a lot of work ahead of
you don't think it's gonna be easy it's
gonna be far from easy
Oh especially when there's that move my
knight has a lot of work to do oh I need
to hang on to my rook I think getting
the rooks off would have been better for
my opponent that's an actual that's a
real suggestion this time that wasn't a
fake
I didn't fake that one that wasn't a
fake okay let's grab this pawn it this
guy I need to get get this pine and push
this guy over here King over here King
this is where it's at just take this
pawn and push this guy to Victory Lane
go pawn you need to run fast
because you are your past you're fast in
your past I think I could take this
right the rooks not around and got to
stop this guy I'm ready to get this guy
24 ticks the grabbes attack this is it
you'll never see me play this ever again
never ever ever the first and the last
time just push that 17 so I should have
just hung on to my rook ah Kings gonna
take the rook now okay give me that okay
where's the forks where are those Forks
give me the forks there's got to be a
fork there's the fork 13 tikka Rooskies
right here right here
stop that pond let me get this guy come
over here grab this guy come on come on
oh all right King you know you want to
play too you know you want to play too
all right where's the mate where's the
mate and - ah man the first you've just
seen the very first and last time I'm
ever playing the drops that's it forget
about it
gee pond you will never move two squares
ever again never oh man what a disaster
the grabs attack why was I being
attacked what did I do and what was I
not doing my opponent played a good game
ah man I like this Knight maneuver and I
really did not see the Knight f5 move
that was I can't explain it man no
explanation for I just it was a blind
spot I didn't even see that
why wasn't I seeing that
him he vowed he just even voluntarily
went there this is uh man I gotta do
something better I don't know again this
is the extent of my knowledge right here
G for you called the grabs attack and
that's about all I know right here I
know that he's a bit annoying to a
knight that comes here but the knight
never came here just went to e7 g6 so
and what should my opponent have how
about we just fast-forward to the spot
where my opponent should have just
punished me yeah cuz I don't know what
should I do here I have to challenge
these guys sooner definitely have to
challenge this Center sooner so how
about how about right now this is fine
because I'm watching over this pond but
after this Bishop move how about maybe
maybe right now or maybe there's
something like Knight a3 and c4 or
something I was just gonna say if I was
to play it again I'd look into that he
said I wasn't gonna play this again oh
man what a nightmare literally those
Knights are killer against my king
probably Forks everywhere
I got very lucky right there c4 mm I
don't know what to suggest other than
just don't play the grabs I don't know I
don't know I mean it should not be that
bad but I guess it could turn out to be
very bad if you just don't know anything
about it like a particular setup and
clearly I'm not able to come up with
anything right now
so this Knight is a giant past I like
this Bishop move inducing this move does
not allow Knight C threes
it's all very nice and these Knights are
brutal and right here the rook move is
very good and that move isn't because of
the trickiness that I have around the
corner so I think maybe all that is
needed is one more patient moves such as
Knight e5 to
for and I think I had I still have some
serious problems with defending c3
Brooke c1 is never an option because of
rook takes Knight so keep that in mind
that's why I wasn't able to defend with
rook c1 and I had to do this move this
was actually my first thought and I was
like it's unprotected on c1 so set
yourself up for tactics but even so even
though I'm up a Brook or I'll excuse me
a knight right here right here I think
I'm in trouble
instead the King move do this I wouldn't
be surprised if maybe this is maybe
winning for black something like pawn
push exchange rooks and then sneak this
King in to get this H pawn and I'm still
struggling to get rid of these guys so
and maybe there's a bit counterintuitive
because of that general principle to
avoid exchanges when you're down
material but in this case a knight
really hates having to defend passed
pawns and he's the only guy that's now
left I want to be able to have a rook so
I think maybe even black stands better
here after something like b5 and it
seems like a draws maybe something I'm
struggling to get anyhow what's my rook
got active the the tables turn here just
grab a pawn and now this Jeep on me
comes past my my Grob pond but yeah this
is a scary very committal opening to be
running with okay good game hi eagle